[Musique]
aux enchères est vite tu vas perdre tout
ce qui te reste
comment elle s'appelle kim sans doute
traque moi ça changera ni l'argent et
c'est de trouver un prêtre plus tôt
vous
je peux vous assurer que mon attention
était purement d'ordre charnelle monde
et nos depuis quand elle tue son amant
trois semaines d'ailleurs c'est mon
record qu'ils aiment ils flora trois
fois adjugé vendu
elle est beaucoup trop sauvage et j'ai
muscles surtout faire
[Musique]
elle a manqué tué ma fille laissez-moi
l'acheter je paierai le prix de votre
choix
j'en ferai une vraie championne qui leur
est bonne blague
mon père veut que j'épouse le compte
guère look si je suis parfaitement à
l'aise
sur bilou
[Musique]
en tant qu'acteur
la débourrer ne servait à rien il
fallait l'adapter à légende raconte
qu'un pad aurait acheté la hongrie avec
un cheval
plus de la perle à cause d'un cheval
c'est bien compris et j'étais assez
clair quant à cela
c'est aussi belle qu'intelligente
georges russe c'est rien de le dire
elle pourrait devenir une grande
championne
entre payer dans baril de poudre et
c'est dûment pourrait bien être
l'étincelle qui fera toutes exposées en
hongrie
l'affrontement qui cherche je dirais que
ça n'a guère plus tôt